porque esta corte de cinta el primer
ministro etíope aviv med inauguró por
todo lo alto la puesta en marcha de la
producción de electricidad de la presa
del renacimiento se necesitaron 10 años
de trabajo para construir la estructura
hidráulica la mayor jamás construida en
áfrica con 145 metros de altura y 18
kilómetros de longitud ya está en
funcionamiento el principal motivo
fueron las dificultades de financiación
los etíopes han tenido que rebuscar en
sus bolsillos para financiar la
infraestructura cuyo coste se estima en
4 mil 200 millones de dólares aunque es
un orgullo nacional para etiopía la
presa ha sido motivo de disputa con
egipto y sudán desde que se puso en
marcha el proyecto en 2011 esto se debe
a que obtiene sus recursos del nilo azul
el principal afluente del nilo del que
ambos países dependen agua como puedes
ver el agua generará energía mientras
fluya como fluía previamente a escasean
y egipto eso a diferencia de los rumores
que dicen que el pueblo y el gobierno
etíopes están regresando el agua para
matar de hambre a
el cairo que anunció en enero que había
caído por debajo del umbral de pobreza
de agua se niega a permitir que etiopía
llene la presa con demasiada rapidez y
amenaza regularmente con una
intervención militar el verano pasado la
onu recomendó que continuaran las
conversaciones diplomáticas entre los
tres países pero esto no impidió que te
opi a lanzar a la segunda fase del
relleno en julio había ahmet que promete
vender la energía producida a precios de
coste a sus vecinos afirma que la presa
beneficiará al desarrollo económico de
toda la región